talked about marco who's been on a
really nice run as of late and they
really need him today 18 starts on the
air five and five record a 4-1-3 era 100
to third he has 79 strikeouts over 30
watts mariners first pitch of the ball
game swung on and sent to left center
field drifting over is jake bowers one
down
[Applause]
there's a line drive base hit into left
field on a 1-2 pitch
all day long beautiful swing we started
him with the fastball which he took then
it was a cutter at 86 miles an hour and
then another heater
kind of pushing him off the plate a
little bit probably a good idea
jammed him kelnick will take care of
this
[Applause]
need a stopping performance by marco
gonzalez really close
jp thought he had him that was perfectly
timed scott service
might want to take a look at it he looks
like he's out to me yep so one six
on the pickup that'll do it for the
royals and the first jp will lead off
when we get back so the royals pitching
staff
has kept the mariners in the ballpark
and now brady singer will make his 23rd
start
dozier recovers and singer is there at
the bag
[Applause]
that pitch is drilled to center field
but taylor got a good angle
and he made that play look routine two
down they have been i think no worse
than seventh
runners in scoring position batting
average in the major leagues start today
fifth and seeger hits one right at the
road he boots it big time
oliveris and seeger will end up at
second
looks like he had that one totally
corralled and it got away and he got
seeger in scoring position with two outs
here in the first inning ty france
couple hits yesterday two for five
tenth in the american lincoln heading
ground ball right under seeger's legs
manny giving a wave on booted out there
by taylor
seeger scores nice and easy and
americans have a one-nothing lead here
in the first
rbi for todd france his 60th of the
season
kellner got a good jump but slicing is
he's there to make the play well done
jared kellnick great break hangs in
stays after it and it's still
one-nothing mariners
that's a slider
olivares will make the play two down
325 six doubles four homers nine
multi-hit games 409 on base percentage
switch hitter plays good defense at
second
today for one he grounded out to win the
first inning first and second two down
and batting left-handed he'll swing at
the first one hit it in the air to
center easy play for michael a taylor
he'll make the catch in the inning and
brady able to work around hitting a
batter and walking a batter
and so he strands two
two outs in a one-two pitch
struck him out one two three in the
fourth good time for that first
strikeout
swinging a miss
he gets taylor in three pitches
back-to-back strikeouts ended the fourth
with a strikeout
excellent location towards the top of
the zone
borderline on the inside corner and gets
him to chase it
probably just off the plate
and brady has struck out his third and
he struck out three of the last four
[Applause]
blue kc pitch tracks to show you this
slider it was nice the last three
pitches were all in there he was fouling
him off and typically pitchers just keep
burying it in there salvi he knows the
weaknesses expose it there 25 year old
brady singer 3-2 pitch
ground ball lopez can't get it face head
just a man second hit comes with two
outs
and he gets a ground ball to short
so singer got one down and out of the
strike zone and he got ty france to
chase it and brady singer has given up
one unearned run in five minutes here's
salvi
in the
53 year history of the royals
seven or more home runs 14 or more rbis
on a single road trip salvi is one
of three
and right on cue
salvador perez hits it off the facing of
the upper deck
so make it eight home runs and 15 rbis
on this trip
salvador perez has now tied
a royals record he has homered in five
straight games
and no catcher in american league
history has ever homered more in a
single season
than salvador perez his 38th
of the year calico strikeout and a walk
today one two pitch
high fly ball deep right field
that's got a chance gideon
[Applause]
his seventh of the season
[Applause]
here is michael a taylor
taylor gets one out over the plate and
that's deep into left field
and the royals answer and taylor puts it
into the second deck
a long home run michael a taylor ties
this game 2-2
his 11th home run on the year
boy michael a got all of that one so
kyle seeger can do with two outs here we
go 1-1 to kyle
did he get enough
let it ride let
[Applause]
home run number 31 a career best in the
mariners have the lead back
shall we fly to center when he faced
sewalled on friday night
and he goes the other way that ball
carries it is off the wall around third
comes lopez the throw to the plate is
not in time and the royals have cut it
to one
what more can perez do
he missed a home run only by a couple of
feet but for now it's 4-3 in the eighth
inning
pitch
that's it hard left field
bowers what a catch
what a great play
jake bowers
great start
terrific fetish great grab
wow
bowers coming in
makes the grab again
jake bowers having a day in left field
two outs in a one run mariner league in
the night this will be the tenth pitch
in this hit back here we go three and
two
took something off ground ball
[Applause]
and that's your ball game baron has won
it by the count of four to three to
salvage a game in this series against
the kansas city royals
[Applause]